what up space fam goes in here from
anime uproar and i'm back at it again
with a new demon slayer video
this time about quite likely the most
popular couple
in all of demon slayer nezuko and
zenitsu
if you do enjoy seeing these demon
slayer videos i want to keep them coming
the best thing you could do is smash
that like button until it's blue
if you haven't make this the video you
subscribe and hit that notification bell
to turn on all notifications or you will
miss future demon slayer videos
let me know what videos you are burning
up to see in the comments a bunch of you
wanted this one after i dropped the
tanjiro and kano's relationship
explained video
so here we are definitely drop a like
and comment if you want me to cover
inosuke and aoi
or mitsuri and iguro next you can find
that hanjiro and kano video along with
many other videos about the hashira
demon moons and much much more
in my demonstrator playlist link to that
is in the description now without
further ado
let's jump into it spoilers and all
zenitsu debuted in chapter
six during the final selection arc along
with kano he didn't really do anything
though he was just singled out for a
second
a little foreshadowing that he along
with kanel and genya would be important
to the story moving forward he's one of
the few people to
pass the exam and when we see him next
during chapter 8
he's the only one of the four presents
stricken by
fear after passing the exam thinking to
himself over and over again
that he's going to die even though he
survived here he'll
die in the end he also gets a sparrow
while the others get a crow which is
pretty hilarious
but yeah let's keep in mind that one of
the main things we know about zenitsu
right from the get-go is that he carries
a lot of fear
this detail will make his later actions
for nezuko all the more significant
it is not until chapter 19 that we see
zanitsu again
and then we figure out another important
aspect of zainto's character aside from
his fear
the dude likes girls a lot and is pretty
shameless when it comes to pursuing them
when tundra sees him and nezuko is in
his wooden backpack
zenitsu is on his knees crying begging
for a random girl to marry him because
he doesn't know when he'll die
he says please countless times after
tanjiro saves the girl from the awkward
situation zaitsu put her in she thanks
tanjiro
zanitsu says the girl likes him and is
going to marry him only to get
repeatedly
slapped and hit by sad girl until tundra
has to save zenitsu this time from the
girl
telling her to calm down we then find
out that this girl
is engaged and all she did was ask
zenitsu
if he was alright because he looked sick
at the side of the road and somehow that
led to zenitsu thinking she liked
him and would marry him zaritsu doesn't
blame himself after she leaves but
rather asks tanjiro
why he interfered and then we get the
memified look of disgust from tanjiro so
yeah so far
zaritsu definitely doesn't look so good
at this point he's like a young
frightened master roshi and tundra looks
at him as if he were some truly pitiful
creature
zenitsu reveals that he's a swordsman
because a woman tricked him and put him
deep
into debt and his trainer was an old man
who took on that debt
so clearly zanitsu does not have a good
track record with girls up to this point
and in part that's because he often
chooses the wrong girl to pursue
whether she's the kind that manipulates
him for money or the kind that's already
taken
zaitsu joins tundra on his journey and
they go to see about a demon in a house
but zenitsu is too scared and sweaty to
want to go in at first
but finally tangero's look of disdain
and pity finally makes xenitou agree to
go
despite his fear tundra leaves nezuko
still in her box with the scared
children but they leave her when they
hear
scratching it is at this point that
tundra says that i quote that box holds
the thing i value most
more important than my life itself end
quote when tanjiro and zenitsu get
separated zainto's immediate plan is to
make it outside with the boy he's with
saints was so scared that the boy is
worried more about zenni too rather than
himself
zanitsu sees a demon he passes out he
enters avatar mode and defeats it and
eventually he makes it outside where he
protects the box nezuko is in from
inosuke who keeps hitting him now here
for the first time
zaritsu has shown a very respectable
side of himself despite all his fear
he was ready to take whatever punishment
inosuke could dish out in order to
protect nezuko's box
yes he didn't really know nezuko yet but
it's significant that she's tied in a
way
to this big moment of his you could
already say that she brought out the
best in him when tanjiro comes out of
the house and sees what's happening
zenitsu tells tundra he protected this
because tanjiro said it was more
important than his own life
this moment would have been powerful no
matter what but it's way more powerful
because
we saw how over the top scared zanetsu
always seemed to be
up to this point yet consciously he
decided to help his new friend despite
all the fear and pain
as we find out he knew from the start
that a demon was in the box because of
his amazing sense of hearing and yet
in all his life he never heard a sound
that was so full of kindness
as the sound that tundra makes so he
decides to trust that there is a good
reason for tanjuro carrying around
a demon and he will protect it no matter
what until he can ask tundra directly
about it it's amazing characterization
for zaitu's character
and when tundra seized a beat-up zany 2
gripping the box to protect it he has
flashbacks of what happened to his
family
possibly even foreshadowing zenitsu's
eventual inclusion in tundra's family
but also showing him that this blonde
dude is actually worthy of friendship
and maybe even worthy of being the
person that protects nezuko am i getting
a little ahead of myself
yeah but all of these moments take on
new significance when we know what's to
come
either way eventually tundra
acknowledges zenitsu
as a really great guy when he finds out
that he protected the box despite
knowing a demon was in it
tundra even said that from the start his
sense of smell
told him that contrary to appearances
zenitsu was actually good and strong
so this was just zanitsu proving what
tundra already
sensed already things are looking good
for zenitsu because of course tanjuro
wouldn't mind his sister ending up with
a good strong guy who would protect
nezuko even before meeting her
despite how scared he was and the risk
he had to undertake in doing so
then we get the first official
face-to-face meeting of zenitsu and
nezuko
at first zenitsu is horrified when she
begins coming out
only to fall in love at first sight when
he actually sees her in his view
she straight up sparkles despite being a
demon zenitsu's first thought
is to be jealous of tanjuro because he
has it so good
being with this cute girl every day and
traveling in pure bliss
keep in mind zenitsu doesn't let tanjuro
explain that it's his sister at first so
zanitsu is appalled that he went through
so much suffering just so tanjuro could
be all lovey-dovey with a girl
after finding out she was tundra's
sister the entire time
zanetsu was on his best behavior wanting
to obtain tundra's forgiveness
after all you want to be on good terms
with a brother if you want to marry his
sister
one of the first things zanitsu did was
present nezuko with flowers
something we'd all recognize as a
romantic gesture for a girl you like
for zanitsu it was a complete 180 from
utter despair to blissful hope
that he now had a chance to end up with
nezuko unlike kano and tanjo's
relationship from the moment zenitsu
sees nezuko his feelings are very
obvious
there is no doubt that he likes her and
wants to marry her
the only question is will she want to
marry him
during the natagumo mountain arc mission
at first zenitsu doesn't follow them up
that scary mountain but as soon as he
remembers that tundra has nezuko with
him he rushes to catch
up calling tundra an idiot for taking a
girl someplace dangerous
again we start to see how nezuko is the
key for zenitsu
overcoming his character flaws like
being paralyzed by excessive fear
and also eventually not being as crazy
about every girl because he has his own
that he can direct all of his love
towards and because
nezuko is a good person he'll no longer
have to be worried about being
manipulated for money which got him here
in the first place
on the mountain when he's scared he also
motivates himself by thinking of his
head
on nezuko's lap if he were dreaming and
he woke up with nezuko
he would work really hard he says he'd
even plow three fields
it's telling that she's the one person
he thinks about not any other woman
when he finds himself in a nightmarish
spider-filled situation like this one
we find out that zenitsu didn't grow up
with parents so no one ever expected
anything of him
until his sensei who he also calls
gramps he thinks of nezuko when he
thinks about a dream of spending his
whole life protecting others or making
them happy
his gramps who never gave up on him
inspires him to actually try to pursue
such a dream
and gives him strength to defeat his
enemy spider demon in epic fashion
still he manages to get so poisoned that
he thinks he's going to die
and in this situation he chooses to
apologize to nezuko
rather than anyone else before shinobu
eventually saves him then we jump to the
rehabilitation arc
where we find out despite his love for
nezuko zanetsu is still into other girls
as well even if the emotions are more
superficial compared to what he feels
for nezuko when he finally gets to
participate in rehabilitation training
he gets
crazy excited about the idea of getting
to touch the girls
getting massages from them getting to
touch their hands with a cup game and
getting to grab them for the tag game
he's so angry that tundra and nosuke
made it seem terrible when the training
is actually heaven
because they got to do all of the above
mentioned stuff with attractive girls
that smell great
and for a while he really did enjoy
those excruciating massages from
aoi and laughed during them while
tanjiro and inosuke were more likely to
cry from the pain
so it would be a stretch to say that
zenitsu stopped noticing other girls as
soon as he met nezuko but notably
he wasn't as pathetic anymore getting on
his knees and begging other girls to
marry him and although he clearly was
still attracted to other girls
nezuko was always the main girl he kept
coming back to in his thoughts
zenytu even stopped coming to see kana
when he kept losing to her in the tag
game and the cup game
despite the fact that as he previously
mentioned it was a joy to just look at
such attractive girls
my point is although he still did
embarrassing things
he clearly wasn't as desperate as he was
before but woman still did have a strong
effect on him as we saw when shinobu
used her charms to motivate him so that
he could master total concentration
breathing
in only nine days significantly though
at the end of the day he'd always seem
to come back to nezuko
as we saw in chapter 51 he'd talked to
her while she was still in her box about
his day and what happened nezuko would
scratch the box to communicate back
which zaitsu could apparently use his op
sense of hearing to understand somewhat
and hearts would appear around him as he
promised to take her to where the flower
he brought her
was blooming this is just one small
scene in the story but such an important
one because
it lets us know that off-screen zenitsu
and nezuko
have been communicating and spending a
lot of time together and although
zanitsu gets physically attracted to
other girls the hearts that appear
around him which connote his love
seem to be reserved for nezuko alone at
the end of chapter 51 during the bonus
page where the mangaka usually gives us
some fun
extra sketches we see that zenitsu is
showing nezuko goldfish
and she seems to be in love with the
sight of them he brought them to nezuko
without asking shinobu
and later got chewed out by aoi for it
which goes to show the lengths he'll go
to
to make nezuko happy these little
moments are important because they show
this isn't a one-sided relationship
nezuko as mentioned communicates back
with zenitsu and appears to enjoy
spending time with him as well
and bonus points go to zenitsu for being
so nice and caring
when it comes to the way he treats
nezuko at the end of chapter 54 on the
bonus page we see zenitsu with hearts in
his eyes carrying nezuko while literally
jumping for joy notably nezuko is
evidently laughing joyfully as well
after seeing this bonus page it's not
surprising that zany two dreams about he
and nezuko running through a field
during the mugen train arc
so that's clearly his greatest wish
which is sweet
obviously he cares about tundra too and
the others
but you'll notice that nezuko takes
priority over everyone
else including all of the girls of his
past and the girls of the butterfly
estate who he found attractive as well
he dreams of making a ring of flowers
for nezuko
which can be viewed like a metaphorical
wedding ring in this instance
and nezuko agrees zainsoo doesn't just
dream of her saying yes to him though he
also
imagines doing acts of service for her
like carrying her
on his back over a river because she
can't swim in contrast tundra dreamt of
his family inosuke dreamt of the whole
gang
only he was the clear leader and then
goku dreamt of his little brother
zenitsu is the only one to dream of a
romantic other
which goes to show how much he cares
about nezuko
and how much she means to him because he
doesn't have a family to remember
except his sensei when zanetsu finds the
infiltrator in his subconscious he tells
him that only nezuko is allowed in there
again reiterating how important she is
to him when nezuko gets into trouble and
caught
by the demon train in real life zenitsu
comes to rescue and frees her using his
thunder breathing proclaiming that he
will protect nezuko and nezuko is
visibly
touched before zanitsu starts snoring
revealing that he's still asleep at the
end of chapter 65 for the bonus page
we straight up see nezuko serving as a
lap pillow
for the sleeping zanitsu and holding his
head so yeah at this point you gotta be
pretty crazy
to think that these two won't end up
together compared to tunjuro and kanao
we've gotten so many more scenes and
clues that these two
are going to end up together and even
though it seems pretty one-sided at
first glance
a closer examination reveals that nezuko
does seem to care about zenitsu and he
clearly
does make her happy which is all the
more significant because he definitely
doesn't always have that effect on other
girls
after the battle with akaza we're told
that zenitsu stopped whining even when
he had to go on missions alone
he did ask for a lock of nezuko's hair
though so that he'll fight harder
although that probably seems weird to
most of us now it wasn't that unheard of
in the past
that a dude would keep a lock of his
love's hair with him
so again it's symbolic of zenitsu and
nezuko's relationship and how he wants
to symbolically keep her with him at all
times
even when they're away from each other
the thought of her gives him motivation
and when he ran with tanjonosuke he
motivated himself by simply yelling out
nezuko's name repeatedly
this my friend is a man deeply in love
if i've ever seen one
from this moment on zenitsu still wants
to protect other girls or come running
if he hears them crying
or show his envy when he hears that the
sound pillar has three wives but nezuko
is the consistent girl he thinks about
as i mentioned before and the one he
wants to make his wife
he is no longer as indiscriminate in his
advances towards women as a roshi or
aminata
now let's fast forward all the way to
when nezuko becomes immune to the sun
and starts speaking again of
course the question is for the purposes
of this video what does she say to
zenitsu and how does that need to
respond to the fact that she can speak
now
and go into the sun well as you may have
imagined zainto is over the moon i just
realized that statement was ironic
he can't help but scream and other girls
are begging him to be quiet
but notably nezico blushes and smiles
saying welcome back to zenitsu the
contrast between her reaction compared
to the other girls is another great sign
for zenitsu nezuko despite being a demon
seems to get him in a way other women
don't he says that nezuko is so cute he
could die now and almost immediately
asks
if they can finally get married now his
expressions say it all
just how insanely infatuated he is with
nezuko
he begs nezuko multiple times to marry
him and promises to feed her sushi and
eel every day if she does
and then nezuko says welcome back
inosuke which makes zenitsu
immediately want to kill inosuke the
thing is nezuko is not fully back to
normal and her speech is still limited
so when inosuke spent the last two days
trying to get nezuko to say his name
it's not surprising that she said it
here
but it's hilarious how it comes off from
zenitsu's perspective
zainsu is clearly so obsessed with
neziko on the one hand
and she appears to not even recall who
he is in this instance
of course naitsu is not actually
discouraged and continues to be
persistent in his efforts to marry
nezuko
the only time zenitsu took a break from
being his nezuko obsessed self
was when he realized that his sensei
died took his own life because nanitsu's
old senpai kaigaku
who also trained under his sensei became
a demon at that point zenitsu started
preparing to defeat him and even tundra
notices he's not his usual cell and so
zenitsu eventually does confront kaigaku
who is now upper moon 6.
zaitsu in a sense has to earn his happy
ending by confronting his fear and his
past
and against kaigaku he actually speaks
arrogantly in contrast to his old
frightened self
he calls kaigaku too slow and eventually
finishes kaigaku with his own
original seventh form of thunder
breathing zanitsu's new attack is so
fast that the demon enhanced kaigaku
can't even
see it finally after he faced his past
and avenged his sensei or gramps as he
called him
zenitsu has arguably earned his happy
ending not only has he been persistent
with nezuko he's also
proven through his actions that he is
worthy of her of course
zenitsu will still help in the fight
against muzon but there's no doubt that
his finest moment
combat wise and character development
wise was his triumph against kaigaku
an upper moon and the man responsible
for his sensei's death
my dude beat an upper moon by himself
while he was
conscious such a great moment and i
can't wait to see it animated now fast
forwarding to the final muzon fight
during chapter 196 nezuko starts
reverting back into a human
and all her memories start to flood in
as well and along with them
she sees a memory of zenitsu offering
her flowers
showing that despite the fact that she
was a demon at the time she has
not forgotten his kind gestures around
the same time zanitsu shows up to help
fight muzon
being the best brother-in-law ever
zenitsu promises tanjo that tanjo's not
going to die rather tundra is going home
with a human nezuko without hesitation
he
risks his life fighting the strongest
demon in an attempt to save tanjiro and
gets slammed into a building in the
process
my boy gets back up to muzon surprise
and even with a broken leg
is able to use his seventh form flaming
thunder god
against muzon he keeps fighting helping
tundra finally pin
muzon to the wall so that he won't be
able to escape the sun
after the whole giant baby moves on
thing manga fans know what i'm talking
about
tundra starts to become the demon king
he attacks
everyone indiscriminately and of course
zanitsu with tears in his eyes
tries to get through to him asking
tanjiro what about nezuko
will he really become a demon and hurt
her like that right after she just
returned to being a human again
at this point it's made clear that even
before the marriage of nezuko and
zanitsu tanjosanitu and inosuke
considered each other brothers
so this fight against demon tundra is
understandably extremely
hard for them inosuke can bring himself
to kill tanjuro and eventually nezuko
steps in in order to try to stop him
she hugs him as tundra bites her not
surprisingly
zanitsu jumps in and hugs tanjuro too
telling him to stop and that he's
killing nezuko as nezuko continues to
get hurt zenitsu cries calling out her
name
unfortunately after all the fighting
he's pretty much out of commission
and he can't stop tundra at this point
luckily as we discussed in my tundra and
kano video
kano comes to the rescue with the
medicine and that along with everyone's
feelings reaching tanjiro
is enough to turn him back into a human
yet again and just as he promised
zenitsu gets to take tundra and nezuko
back home before that though we do get a
great part where tundra is back to
normal and inosuke comments that the
injuries tunjuro gave him
are not a big deal but zenitsu says that
for the rest of tundra's life he'll make
him regret what he did to zaritsu's wife
nezuko now fully human and more shy than
her demon self
is nervous at hearing the word wife and
is shown sweating but significantly
enough
she doesn't say she won't be zenitu's
wife which we gotta admit
is a huge win and she might be the first
girl not to immediately reject him
during chapter 204 we get a moment
between sun emi the wind pillar and
nezuko remember
senemy hurt nezuko and wanted to kill
her while she was a demon
and so this is an important scene where
he finally apologized and pretty much
admitted that he was wrong about her he
saw his little brother in her and so
when to pat her on the head
sonomy is an older guy and not nezuko's
brother
so understandably she gets embarrassed
sweating and blushing as he says take
care we see zaritsu spying on them and
he gets angry and jealous
wondering what it is he just saw however
he has nothing to worry about since he
ends up being the one who goes to live
with nezuko and tundra along with
inosuke we get scenes of nezuko petting
and comforting zenitsu when he complains
about it being dark and how hungry he is
and although he's tired he definitely
doesn't mind being comforted by nezuko
when tanjiro and nezuko make it home
they're greeted and hugged by a neighbor
and hilariously enough
zenitsu joins in on the hug while
inosuke watch is confused like what is
this hug thing
when they pray for the deceased
significantly enough tundra is on one
side of nezuko and zeitu on the other on
the last page
zenitsu and nezuko are sitting and
eating beside each other they're smiling
at each other and passing food as hearts
continue to float around zaitsu's head
and that is at the ending of the main
story before we jump to the giant time
skip that reveals the descendants
of our main characters in this final
chapter we find out that yes in fact
zaintsu and nezuko did get together and
their descendants are called
yoshiteru agatsuma a 17 year old who
looks like zanitsu with black hair and
his older sister the 18 year old
toko agatsuma who looks exactly like
nezuko
in fact the chapter starts with
yoshiteru aka zaitsu's great-grandson
reading a book senitsu wrote about their
demon slaying adventures the hilarious
thing
is also that he called the book the
legend of zenitsu
that definitely cracked me up and at the
end of this chapter we see a framed
image of our main characters
in the kamado house and nezuko and
zenitsu are shown together both leaning
into each other
and that is it the end of the series or
at least that was the end before we got
the bonus extended ending
that was released within the final
volume of the manga i covered this in a
previous video link in the description
if you want more information about it
but from a santu and nezuko perspective
it does give us some significant extra
info we get scenes of tundra and nezuko
beginning to cry when they sense the
presence of their family
when they come home and zenitsu joins in
on the cry and group hug
and this time a nervous inosuke even
tries his hand at the group hug
another hilarious moment and this is the
first time that i noticed that inosuke
after not participating in a hug
the previous time that he does in fact
participate this time which is
just amazing we get some more panels of
zenitsu looking all lovey-dovey at
nezuko and thinking that she's too
obliging to industry when he insists on
having his height measured
immediately we are also told that
because of the after effects of
zaintsu's injuries
he kept crying about his painful legs
while they walked to put flowers on all
the graves
and while inosuke ignored him nezuko
decided to carry him on her shoulders
which is so sweet yet another sign of
nezuko caring about and taking care of
zenitsu we also get some more
information about the descendants and
see yoshiteru and toko's two little
sisters one of who looks like a female
zetsu with the exact same eyebrows
but very cute nonetheless we see some
other scenes
including more scenes of zenitsu and
nezuko laughing together and even a
scene that could be nezuko and zhang to
getting married where tenetsu finally
puts that ring of flowers that he
dreamed of making
on nezuko's head to her great delight
and his sparrow even helps him put it on
her which is a nice disney-esque
touch a happy ending for these two is
exactly what we wanted and needed
and i'm so glad we got it in the final
panel
just as tundra is holding kano's hand
zains was holding nezuko's hand
as they look off into the sky together
and that is it
everything there is to know about zainto
and nezuko's relationship
which is in many ways the most focused
on ship in the entire series although i
explained how an observant person could
pick up on the fact that tanjuno and
kano would end up together it's much
more obvious throughout the story with
zainto nezuko
as from the get-go zanitsu is extremely
upfront about his romantic feelings and
repeatedly asks nezuko to marry him
i hope i've also shown that there were
signs that not only did zenitsu
show feelings for nezuko but nezuko also
showed signs that she'd end up with
zenith as well
she always enjoyed his company unlike
pretty much every other girl
and when she became fully human again
she was ready to fully return his
feelings
this relationship is in part such a
satisfying one because it was
always so obvious how much sanitsu loved
nezuko
and so i was really rooting for him to
get his happy ending with her especially
considering his past where he was
completely alone except for a woman who
used him for money and eventually his
sensei he started out as an
orphan but ended up being a part of this
beautiful family with nezuko
and tanjiro and they clearly go on to
start their own family as well
one that will continue to have many
descendants for nezuko it's a win too
because she doesn't just get
the obsessed over every woman scaredy
cat that zenitsu was in the beginning of
the series
rather zanitsu has grown from begging
random girls on the street to marry him
to focusing on one that likes him and
will treat him right
he also was always very kind and
considerate to nezuko even when others
couldn't see her as a human and just
viewed her as a demonic monster
furthermore he proved that he was able
to overcome his fear when it came to
protecting nezuko and with nezuko there
to motivate him
he ended up becoming one of the
strongest swordsmen alive
many of you said in the comments of the
kano and tanjiro video that nezuko and
zanitsu were your favorite couple
in the series and i can totally see why
these two
are great together and nezuko truly
brought out the best in
zenitsu and that is it for this one this
one will probably be even longer than
the last one because as i mentioned this
is the ship in the series with the most
material to talk about
if you're still with me i just want to
say thank you so much for watching such
a long video all the way to the end
if you do enjoy these demon slayer
videos and want to keep them coming the
best thing you could do is smash that
like button until it's blue
if you haven't make this the video you
subscribe and hit that notification bell
to turn on all notifications or you will
miss future demon slayer videos and
while you wait let me know what videos
you are burning up to see in the
comments definitely drop that like and
comment if you want me to cover inosuke
and aoi
or mitsuri and igoro next plus you can
find the tanjon kano video along with
many other videos about the hasha demon
moons and much more
in my demonstrator playlist link to that
is in the description
and i especially want to thank the
patron squad over on patreon here on
youtube who helped make videos like this
one possible first and foremost i want
to thank the patron of legend the one
acknowledged by lord tuigo himself alpha
sigma and are the one tier patrons the
ones who stand atop all clans
ingrata but they have the algatal dr
cortman the toasted chi
the spike emperor taku spidey life tinel
tungsten tarkis big buddhist cody hebert
and monkey d
quilly and our pro hero tier patrons the
one and only gilgamesh the red haired
raven angel cruz anatoly kazatsuki very
gucci alicia actor bonnie parks hinokami
water joy and garcia ted no 10 fat boy
games cory mcgohan metal mama deadly
saint and soul ride slice and dice thank
you all
so much if you do enjoy our work you can
support more of it by going over to
patreon.com
anime upper and becoming a patron today
for as little as one dollar if you do
still get your name featured in future
videos alongside these amazing people
right here and you'll get access to our
private patron only discord where we
talk about manga chapters anime life
and of course dank memes so check out
patreon.com anime opera
link in the description if you're
interested you can also join the youtube
channel by clicking that blue join
button next to subscribe button they've
hopefully already destroyed
a lot of you guys have been doing that
which i love to see so yeah you can
definitely support that way as well and
whichever way to support us you will get
the same
great benefits thanks again and until
next time
see you space cowboys
[Music]
you